Brussels Berlin Copenhagen throughout
Europe people have been protesting
against the EU Canada trade deal a
popular uprising that highlighted
European citizens concerns about the e
use free trade policy to head off
further unrest and peas are looking into
the issue at stake is the legitimacy of
the EU strayed deals the apartment is up
come on grow by Z ultra light and
padding's is the Forgotten hi sue vini
in a variety discutir fun soufeel Hindu
philosophy on does most transparency and
widen this restriction Donovan I for
Glavine fafa the EU has a fifteen
percent share of the global trade in
goods transport textiles chemicals food
and drink you exports are doing well
with a positive trade balance of 64
billion euros in 2015 the recent
signature of the Canada deal should give
a further boost to trade for the
Commission it's now up to the Parliament
to ensure its swift ratification this
agreement with Canada cita as we used to
call it is a good if not an excellent
example of how the European Union can
actually shape global trade policy and
thereby shaping globalization itself the
Canada deal is on track but negotiations
with the United States the e u--'s
number one export partner are at risk
following the election of Donald Trump
during the course of his electoral
campaign the president-elect hinted at
breaking off talks with the EU